tous je demande aux intervenants
suivants de me rejoindre sur scène qui
est jean louis bal fabien shawn
jean-louis salanave thierry lepercq
qu'elle enlevait très nombreux 1 pour la
table ronde énergie on va essayer
respecter le timing sinon nicolas va me
tirer les oreilles
jean claude lenoir hervé mariton
dominique louis ça va faire 8 je crois
donc cette question de l'énergie c'est
une question centrale à la fois pour la
france est à la fois pour les
républicains et on peut pas dire que la
loi sur la transition énergétique nous a
satisfaits
on a plutôt eu tendance à revenir en
arrière
néanmoins vous me connaissez vous savez
que je suis pro énergies renouvelables
mais c'est pas parce qu'on est pro
énergies renouvelables qu'il faut
investir dans le renouvelable qu'il faut
évidemment et on l'a vu avec la
recherche aller vers une nouvelle
technologie qu'il faut arrêter notre
nucléaire qui est une ressource qui est
non émettrice de co2 et c'est bien ça
aujourd'hui l'urgence on vient de
l'évoquer toute la matinée alors autour
de cette halle je voulais donner la
parole à monsieur balle pour tout ce qui
concerne justement les énergies
renouvelables tu es président du
syndicat nous faire un peu un état des
lieux de ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui du
développement de deux peut-être
probablement de du fait que les français
sont son meneur aussi sur ceux question
est est-ce qu'on va pouvoir imposer des
technologies qui fonctionne et est réglé
rapidement les questions de stockage de
ce qu'on l'a rappelé une des inquiétudes
les énergies renouvelables marche pas
tout le temps le solaire c'est environ
je crois que 15 % du temps l'éolien
environ 25% du temps donc voilà en
france donc c'est vrai que il ya encore
une marge de progression je t'écoute
oui bonjour à toutes et à tous un tout
petit mot pour présenter le syndicat
parce que je sais pas si sûr que tout le
monde le connaît sans donc c'est la
principale association professionnelle
du secteur des énergies renouvelables on
regroupe 350 entreprises
tous les grands énergéticiens
industriels de l'énergie vais pas les
citer parce que j'ai pas là pour faire
de la publicité mais sont tous membres
donc du syndicat et c'est aussi 80% de
deux pme et
notre quotidien c'est de concilier
écologie et progrès technologique nous
avons beaucoup de startups que nous
arrivons regarder sur le sur le
territoire et nous quand nous regardons
la question de la transition énergétique
nous ne nous limitons pas au territoire
français
nous ne limitons pas à la métropole
c'est un un phénomène qui est qui et
mondial nous ne limitons pas non plus
notre champ d'intervention à
l'électricité qui ne représente au
niveau mondial et au niveau français qu'
environ un tiers de nos consommations
donc on a évoqué la question des
transports il faut aussi évoquer le
secteur du bâtiment tout ce qui est
production de chaleur sur lequel donc
nous avons nous avons des des activités
est aujourd'hui le constat que l'on fait
c'est la révolution énergétique dans le
monde c'est pas les gaz de schiste c'est
pas des pétroles de schiste c'est les
énergies renouvelables qui ont alors est
juste coup parce que je pense qu'on ne
reviendra pas sur l'histoire des
schistes des gaz de schiste des machins
est ce que bon voilà mais juste un mot
pour vous dire que la position du parti
elle est contre la fracturation
hydraulique controversé mais pour la
recherche encore une fois pour la
recherche parce qu'il semble
inacceptable aujourd'hui de ne pas
chercher des techniques alternatives et
de ne pas georges c'est vrai que on en
reparlera après je connais les positions
des états unis nous amènerait que le
parti devait se positionner
il se positionne sur la recherche sur
l'exploration c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être pas l'énergie de demain dans
lequel nous allons devoir aller
néanmoins aujourd'hui le gaz c'est
l'énergie la plus complémentaire quand
on fait du renouvelable
ce comme le renouvelable en principe est
intermittent ça permet de déclencher
quelque chose
automatiquement beaucoup plus rapidement
et ça c'est le gaz et c'est bien plus
efficace au niveau
émissions de co2 que le charbon est une
centrale nucléaire ne se déclenche pas
aussi rapidement donc ça peut juste être
un bon mixte donc on rachète pas tout en
bloc
mais on est pour la recherche et pour
les techniques non polluantes et toutes
les énergies renouvelables ne sont pas
intermittente je rappelle quand même que
la principale de nos énergies
renouvelables et groen en parlant baky
et renouveler les est vraiment le
meilleur complément des énergies dites
intermittente puisque le l'hydraulique
peut intervenir extrêmement rapidement
quand il ya des baisses devant quand il
ya plus d'ensoleillement pendant la nuit
et c'est donc
relativisons tout cela maintenant quand
on regarde dans le monde aujourd'hui les
grands investissements qui se font dans
le secteur de l'électricité
les deux tiers sont pour les énergies
renouvelables représentent à peu près
300 milliards en 2015 avec une
progression de 5 ou 10 % chaque année et
ça se ventile en gros c'est un tiers
dans l'hydraulique un tiers dans
l'éolien et un tiers dans le
photovoltaïque
et pourquoi c'est ce développement qui a
été longtemps tiré par les pays
développés avec des mécanismes de
soutien des subventions dont il est
question dans le document pourquoi ce
développement
si dynamique ces dernières années eh
bien à cause des progrès de
compétitivité donc de ces énergies
le dernier chiffre il est sorti hier un
appel d'offres à dubaï pour une centrale
solaire photovoltaïque est sorti à 30 $
du mégawattheure 25 euros du
mégawattheure pour comparaison donc le
le coût estimé du nucléaire en france et
50 euros du mégawattheure alors
évidemment c'est un ensoleillement de
dubaï
si on transpose ça à l'ensoleillement de
france je me retourne vers vers thierry
mais à peu près à 50 euros du
mégawattheures également le soutien au
photovoltaïque
il a été mis en place donc en 2006 avec
à l'époque un tarif d'achat obligé par
edf qui était de 300 euros du
mégawattheure en 2011 ça a été remplacée
par une procédure d'appel d'offres au
dernier appel d'offres la moyenne des
projets qui ont été
sélectionnée c'était 82 euros du
mégawattheures avec le moins cher à 71
et dans les prochains appels d'offres
ça va continuer à descendre voilà il ya
toute une dynamique et qu'on retrouve
d'ailleurs aussi dans les techniques de
stockage et qu'on retrouve également
donc dans les progrès que l'on réalise
dans les départements d'outre-mer où là
on est obligés maintenant avec ces
petits systèmes électriques de recourir
des systèmes de stockage
voilà c'est pas uniquement l'électricité
les énergies renouvelables c'est aussi
la production de chaleur et c'est
notamment à la les chaufferies bois et
j'ai bien entendu les les critiques du
sénateur de côte-d'or que je partage
d'ailleurs ce qui ne dévalorise pas le
fait de faire des chaufferies biomasse
simplement il suffit pas de mettre en
place une chaufferie il faut aussi
organiser l'approvisionnement à côté et
ne pas aller chercher dans le jura
dubois qui se trouve à quelques
kilomètres de dijon où j'ai beaucoup
contribué au développement du réseau de
chaleur de vision et de la chaufferie
biomasse et est donc c'est un secteur
que je connais bien voilà c'est pas
uniquement la chaleur c'est aussi des
transports et dans les transports
ça a été évoqué à la table ronde
précédente c'est extrêmement compliqué
de de réduire l'empreinte écologique des
transports on aura affaire à des petits
bouts de solutions on a aujourd'hui déjà
des choses que tout le monde ne sait pas
mais quand vous voulez pour utiliser
votre voiture vous avez entre 7 et 8 %
de biocarburants dans votre dans votre
carburant et ça va continuer à se
développer
il ya également donc tout ce qui est
production de gaz d'origine renouvelable
on va développer on fait déjà des gars
des véhicules de gaz naturel et on aura
bientôt du bio jnv
qui sera donc du gaz d'origine d'origine
renouvelable
et ça ça profitera aussi au monde
agricole pour laquelle ce sera une
source supplémentaire de revenus
donc on voit bien que on consomme de
l'énergie à tour de bras que les pays en
développement veulent avoir accès à ces
thèmes énergie mais que des solutions
existent et que va bien falloir qu'on
trouve des techniques pour prélever le
minimum de la nature et c'est pour ça
que je suis très heureuse quand il ya
des startups françaises qui émergent et
avec un potentiel aussi de marchés
internationaux
c'est pour ça que chiffre à oui c'est
les énergies renouvelables en france
c'est 23 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
ces cent mille emplois directs et donc à
peu près autant d'indirects donc c'est
quand même un secteur et dernière des
choses
j'oserais dire que le développement des
renouvelables électriques
il n'est pas incompatible avec le père
fut clair il faut absolument
impérativement faire les deux et prendre
des bonnes décisions basées sur les
faits alors pour juste rentrer encore un
peu plus dans le détail sur le solaire
je voulais que tirer le père qui est le
pdg de solairedirect dise un mot parce
que bon voilà il est vraiment précurseur
dans cette thématique là et surtout sur
le développement international alors
qu'on est il réellement du marché quel
est le potentiel international il ya un
savoir faire français que tu mets en
avant
quel est ton bilan la situation mais
d'abord l'heure solaire direct c'est
effectivement une pme une entreprise
entrepreneuriale créé il ya dix ans par
une équipe de sept fondateurs qui
aujourd'hui fournissent de l'électricité
grosso modo sa propre et 1000 mégawatts
installés sur quatre continents fournit
l'électricité à peu près pour un million
de personnes
mais ce qui est vraiment le plus
important c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
rejoint le groupe mgi et je vais parler
avec beaucoup de force au nom du groupe
mgi que je suis heureux de représenter
aujourd'hui le premier groupe
énergétique mondial présent dans 70 pays
115 gigawatts 155 mille personnes et qui
va vivre un moment très important dans
quelques heures
puis ce qui va changer de direction et
je si je puis me permettre
avec une femme aux commandes ça va
décoiffer
non et je connais tu manges eux
on a rit on n'a rien on n'a rien vu et
je me réjouis que des femmes puissent
faire bouger le monde parce que dans le
cas de la dgi c'est vraiment le cas
alors de quoi s'agit-il
je crois que jean louis bal à 10,25
euros 25 euros je vais la faire simple
aujourd'hui on vit un moment totalement
historique
on parle d'une énergie quasiment
infinies pour savoir parce qu'on a parlé
tout à l'heure de l'espace avec un tiers
de ce qu'on est aujourd'hui en culture
en bioéthanol onfray 100 % de la
consommation électrique de la france
pour produire en anglais on n'a pas
besoin d'arrêter de manger pour produire
l'électricité solaire
c'est une énergie infinie qui devient
quasiment gratuite quasiment gratuite un
fini quasiment gratuite
alors elle a juste un petit problème tu
l'a mentionné c'est qu'elle est variable
mais on a une autre source en france et
cette ressource
là encore elle a été incarnée par
isabelle kocher il ya huit jours à à à
new york elle était devant un ministre
alors c'était pas un ministre français
c'était un ministre indien le ministre
indien de l'énergie
alors pourquoi l'inde d'ailleurs l'inde
a lancé a été à l'origine pour ce qui
nous concerne chez ceux-là diack nous
avons joué un rôle majeur là dedans
l'avion solaire internationale à lyon
solaire internationale ces 120 pays
c'est 1000 milliards de dollars
d'investissements dans le solaire
mobilisés par ces pays et dont pige de
galles et il avait le kocher ont annoncé
le lancement formel de lui pendant
priver de cette initiative qui s'appelle
la térawatts initiative et qu'elles
soient les français étaient en première
ligne alors les français c'est qui ces
groupes angie dont je viens de parler
le groupe total peu de gens ont noté
groupe total qui vient qui a rejoint
dans internet initiative il ya un mois
patrick pouyanné a annoncé que son
groupe allait basculer des hydrocarbures
vers l'électricité solaire et m excusez
du peu 30 milliards de dollars sur la
table pour faire dans 20 ans son groupe
un leader mondial de l'électricité
solaire bien au delà de tout ce qu'ils
ont fait il ya une autre entreprise qui
a joint rejoint et là on va toucher un
autre sujet sensible qui schneider
electric
schneider electric c'est un leader
mondial de l'intelligence énergétique et
aujourd'hui on est confronté à un sujet
où les enjeux énergétiques
ce n'est plus simplement la ressource
quelque part cette ressource l'encan
j'insiste une ressource infinie
quasiment gratuite et les chinois je
prends l'exemple de la chine gta juste
parenthèse quand même pour mesurer la
chose j'étais aux berlines de transition
d'ailleurs quelque 21 allemands dont il
ya un mois à berlin il y avait 1200
personnes ont été dits français pas très
nombreux il y avait une délégation
chinoise très imposante
le gouvernement chinois a pour objectif
de faire mille gigawatts mille centrales
nucléaires en solaire d'ici 2030 2035
n'ont pas longtemps c'est la chine
voilà c'était en train de partir les
indiens court d'ailleurs pour revenir à
ce que je voulais dire sur la
technologie française
on a une carte extraordinaire à jouer et
elle s'incarne dans cette initiative
térawatts elle s'incarne dans la
mobilisation de ses champions français
qui sont certes des grands groupes mais
aussi effectivement des pme y compris
les pme technologique
nous avons une carte technologique de la
french tech 1 ce terme est un peu
galvaudé mais je voudrais insister là
dessus aujourd'hui transformer cette
énergie variable la dompter elle a donc
t'es pas uniquement en faisant du
stockage qui est très bien mais il ya
énormément de choses qu'on peut faire on
peut utiliser faire la mobilité
électrique
on peut gérer la demande on peut grâce à
ses technologies de l'information le big
data
l'internet des objets où nous avons des
leaders mondiaux en france nous avons
une carte extraordinaire d'une
plateforme technologique aujourd'hui et
ça ça répond à des besoins dans le monde
entier j'étais il ya quinze jours avec
le président du kenya qui était en
visite à paris
quand on lui a expliqué tout ça il m'a
dit et on était là l'équipe de france
c'était au siège du medef un petit peu
plus il nous a dit moi je veux voir
l'équipe de france à nairobi la semaine
prochaine nous avons aujourd'hui une
carte incroyable à jouer parce que
effectivement il ya à la fois des grands
programmes qui se font en inde en chine
et ses terrains mais il ya surtout une
offre à créer et l'offre france
aujourd'hui elle se met en place
la vision d'entreprise de très grandes
entreprises et là encore demain sa
bande-annonce trop en fait
concernant angie qui vont montrer qu'on
va tout à fait dans cette direction là
donc à agir à mettre au débat sur à mon
avis un atout incroyable de la france
vraiment pas uniquement pour notre
propre approvisionnement énergétique
mais pour notre rayonnement mondial
grâce notamment à ses technologies et
ses entreprises
mais merci beaucoup thierry ça fait
plaisir de voir donc cette énergie est
dedans avant tout comme ça balayé un
petit peu qu'elle en était l'état de la
technique aujourd'hui on voit que ça
progresse et ça progresse vite et c'est
tant mieux et j'espère que ça vous
restera encore et qu en effet la france
pourra avoir rayonné dans des pays très
ensoleillée qui en ont qui en ont besoin
alors je voulais qu'on fasse avec vous
fabien choné vous êtes directeur général
de direct energie je voulais qu'on fasse
un point sur le coup justement de
l'énergie le coût des différentes
énergies et les politiques de
financement de ces énergies et notamment
la grande question de la csp eu des
subventions à l'énergie
voilà vous nous aidiez un mot oui merci
beaucoup merci de votre invitation
bonjour à tous juste pour rappel aussi
d'eric énergie donc c'est le troisième
acteur de l'exciter du gaz en france
avec plus d'un million six cent mille
clients desservis un peu plus d'un
milliard de chiffre d'affaires l'année
dernière est également producteur
d'électricité à partir de gaz
aujourd'hui avec nos centrales en
exploitation dans son de la france et
une autre en développement en bretagne
oui sur la question là de la transition
énergétique et son coût moyen il ya un
point qui me paraît important
alors là c'est ce que juste pour rappel
les chiffres le développement des
énergies renouvelables a coûté entre
2010 et 2013 dans ses clips de la creuse
la commission de régulation l'énergie à
peu près 10 milliards d'euros aux
français dans le cadre de la cspe est
l'hypothèse de la creuse c'est contre
2014 et 2025 ça va coûter à peu près 70
milliards d'euros dont un peu moins de
la moitié pour le photovoltaïque
alors j'ai aucun doute sur le fait qu'un
jour ça sera gratuit ce sera gratuit ce
sera formidable
mais enfin la réalité des français sur
les dix ans qui viennent c'est que ça va
coûter quand même encore un petit peu
d'argent
et on a un petit peu moins de soleil que
dans les pays cités donc donc il faut
quand même regarder les choses d'un
point de vue économique il ya quand même
des arbitrages à regarder et moi en
matière de transition énergétique et sur
cette question du financement de la
transition énergétique
alors je remet pas du tout en cause
l'objectif à terme d'avoir 100% énergies
renouvelables et parce que j'ai pas dit
l'équipe de qualitair je parlais à terme
peut-être à très long terme et à terme
il faudra avoir 100% énergies
renouvelables c'est une certitude
- la question j'ai envie qu'on pose
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est la
question qu'on doit se poser quand on
est aux commandes et au peuple de l'état
c'est de savoir comment on y arrive et
sur cette question là moi je regrette
qu'on ne pose jamais la question du
surcoût des énergies renouvelables entre
le surcoût de production qui dépend
notamment de l'état de la filière qui
était relativement cher au départ
peut-être beaucoup moins cher demain
mais également un deuxième niveau de
surcoût que personne non personne ne
parle
c'est la question du développement des
énergies renouvelables au regard du
besoin
pourquoi parce qu'en fait quand on
regarde le système électrique alors
c'est dû à des facteurs exogènes la
crise économique d'autres problématiques
les quotas co2 fâche pas rentrer dans le
détail mais on a relativement peu de
besoin de nouvelles centrales de
production
or en développement des énergies
renouvelables à marche forcée sans se
poser la question des besoins
on est en train de créer des
surcapacités colossal qui ont deux
impacts soit on est fondre les prix de
marché c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
et quand on est fondée prix de marché la
cspe elle est calculée à la différence
entre le prix entre le coût de
production et le prix de marché
donc quand on est fondre le prix de
marché parce qu'on a développé des
surcapacités et bien la csbe gonfle
énormément bien au delà du surcoût réel
des ménages et la banque s'est même pas
l'intérêt pour les énergies
renouvelables parce que aujourd'hui on
affiche un surcoût d'énergies
renouvelables après 5 milliards d'euros
pour l'année 2016 en réalité dans ses 5
milliards d'euros il ya effectivement
quelques sur coup parce que ça reste
quand même plus cher que les moins de
production classiques mais il ya surtout
énormément de coups qui correspondent au
fait qu'on a été
j'avais dire plus vite que la musique on
a voulu aller beaucoup plus vite que nos
besoins et ce sera encore vrai ça sera
évidemment encore vrai puisqu'on
continue à voir évolutif développement
qui sont très importants tout cas
beaucoup plus important que que nos
besoins
l'autre solution s'était classé des
centrales mais là ça crée des coups
joués pour les opérateurs est
aujourd'hui des classes et des centrales
notamment quand on parle de centrales
nucléaires alors même qu'elles sont
elle fonctionne et ce en état de
fonctionnement les scènes l'a dit ça
crée des surcoûts des coûts et jouer
voire des analyses à sion quand il ya
des des impacts de cette nature donc il
ya un coup également pour la qualité qui
est très important il paraît nécessaire
quand on se pose la question de la
tranche d'âge éthique de séparer le
surcoût des énergies renouvelables qui
va décroissant avec le surcoût est liée
à la vitesse qu'on impose à cette
transition énergétique et de ce point de
vue là il ya la question qu'on doit se
poser tout c'est pourquoi on veut aller
aussi vite
et là il ya un élément qui est
intéressant dans la transition
énergétique sais que si je veux dire la
non sa couleur puisque ça s'appelle en
fait la loi trio magique et de
croissance verte
ce qu'on nous dit c'est que on va aussi
vite pour pouvoir développer de l'emploi
tant dans la filière d'énergies
renouvelables alors moi je sers tous
peut-être cinq cent mille emplois très
bien moi j'ai cru comprendre qu'elle
aime beaucoup de panneaux qui avaient
été fabriqués à l'étranger c'est
regrettable
est ce qu'on aurait pu faire autrement
est ce que ça marche d'investir autant
d'argent je rappelle encore 70 milliard
d'euros dans les dix ans qui viennent
quand même beaucoup d'argent est ce que
ça marche c'est de la première question
la deuxième question c'est est ce qu'on
doit pas également développer des
filières sur lequel on est déjà parmi
les meilleurs du monde et notamment
nucléaires est ce que l'on doit vraiment
et là je suis d'accord et jean louis est
ce qu'on doit vraiment fermer des
centrales
et puis perdre du savoir-faire et de
compétences dans des filières on était
les meilleurs pour essayer de rattraper
notre retard dans les filières on a du
retard il faut dire les choses comme
elles sont est-ce qu'on va y arriver
c'est une vraie question mais surtout
surtout parce que tout ça c'est le choix
politique c'est pas moins industriel de
définir la réponse à ces choix
politiques et surtout surtout est-ce que
c'est aux consommateurs d'électricité de
payer ça est-ce que c'est aux
consommateurs d'électricité de payer le
coût d'une politique en faveur de
l'emploi qui a été définie sur la
croissance verte
nous on estime que non très clairement
c'est un très mauvais signal qu'on on
envoie alors pourquoi est-ce que je
porte le message a aujourd'hui c'est pas
du tout pour faire plaisir
aux producteurs nucléaires à edf
d'ailleurs je précise qu'on n'est pas
concurrent d'edf nucléaire puisque la
production nucléaire dans monopole de
fait en france dont les concurrents
d'edf dans ses autres types de
production et dans sa commercialisation
mais si on tient à souligner ce point là
c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui si vous
regardez l'évolution de la facture
d'exister des français sur les cinq
dernières années il ya augmenté d'à peu
près 25% vous remarqué que plus de la
moitié est liée en fait à l'évolution de
la csp et ça c'est alors même que la
cspe a évolué beaucoup mais peu par
rapport à ce qu'elle va y jouer dans
l'avenir
or si vous regardez le prix des crises
tt qu'il a évolué il a évolué sur les 5
années à peu près au niveau de
l'inflation
et encore quand vous regardez pourquoi
il a évolué c'est essentiellement à
cause du développement des réseaux et
lui-même nécessaire rendue nécessaire
par développement des énergies
renouvelables
donc ce qui nous préoccupe nous
particulièrement aujourd'hui en tant que
nouvel entrant sur ce marché là c'est
que tout le monde où la plupart des gens
attribuent les évolutions de factures à
la hausse à la libéralisation et ça
c'est catastrophique parce que vous
entendez régulièrement les gens disent
que la cause de ces os c'est la
libéralisation alors que c'est pas du
tout la réalité
et alors même que la libéralisation et
la déréglementation du secteur et rick
n'est pas le problème mais la solution
une des solutions en tout cas pour
atteindre de la compétitivité de la
productivité donc dé modération
tarifaire mais pas que ça permet
également d'avoir de l'innovation et ça
c'est très important dans le domaine de
l'efficacité énergétique qui a été citée
également par hamon voyant dans le
domaine des smart grid dans le cadre
développement des compteurs linky qui
vont eux-mêmes coûté d'ailleurs
plusieurs milliards d'euros mais c'est
également source d'investissements
diversifiés donc à moindre coût et ça ça
nous paraît très important que les
politiques puissent enfin annoncé la
nécessité et défendre la nécessité d'une
hybridation pleine et entière ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas et je vous
donner un exemple un exemple un exemple
précis le ministre l'actuelle ministre
de l'économie monsieur macro qui
paraît-il et d'idéal disait devant
l'assemblée nationale n'y a pas très
longtemps à bailly difficulté d'edf sont
en partie dus à la libéralisation c'est
un problème et s'armer quand on regarde
ce qu'il envisage de faire en matière
d'augmentation de capital d'edf car
effectivement situation financière
compliquée on s'en rend compte
entre 4 et 5 milliards on se rend compte
que ça correspond exactement à ce que
madame royal a effacé comme hausse des
tarifs réglementés qui était censé
couvrir les coûts d'edf
il ya deux ans donc si madame royal
n'avait pas par pure démagogie il faut
dire les choses comme elles sont je
pense qu'ici on peut le dire effacer
cette hausse alors qu'elles étaient
nécessaires pour couvrir les coûts d'edf
edf n'aurait pas eu besoin de cette
augmentation de capital
parce que je vous rappelle un destin des
articles de loi est un génie qui est
passée complètement inaperçue
il est écrit maintenant dans la loi
française que le tarif réglementé ne
couvrent plus les coûts de l'opérateur
historique
donc on impose à l'opérateur historique
de vendre à perte
comment voulez vous que les nouveaux
entrants puissent venir investir dans le
marché français alors qu'on affiche dans
la loi française que l'opérateur
historique va être obligé de vendre à
perte à l'ensemble des consommateurs
donc il faut vraiment remettre les
points sur les i dire que la concurrence
doit pouvoir se développer assumer les
coûts et assumer des choix politiques
qui sont fait à la fois en maternelle
genou là mais également en matière
d'emploi si on veut investir tous ces
milliards sur l'emploi vers moi j'aime
bien parler d'emploi bleu parce que je
pense que l'enjeu c'est plus c'est aussi
la question des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et de ce point de vue là la
filière nucléaire est un atout énorme
aussi bien que la filière renouvelable
et en tout cas nous ce qui nous paraît
vraiment important c'est qu'on arrête de
taper sur la libération qui est vraiment
source de solutions et pas source de
problèmes merci merci beaucoup
fabien choné vous retrouverez évidemment
beaucoup de ces propos dans le document
d'orientation que nous avons réalisée
avec grand nombre d'experts qui a été à
mes côtés dont je vois claude ringot ici
beaucoup de personnes qui vont aider à
réaliser ce travail très important et
vous allez voir que cette cette
libéralisation va être au coeur du
projet d'alternance je voulais que
donnait la parole alors je sais que je
vais pas le voulait réintervenir on va
peut-être faire déjà un premier tour
voire le temps qui nous reste je voulais
voir avec le professeur salanave un
petit peu justement cet état des lieux
actuel et notamment notre richesse
depuis tout le temps et depuis le
général de gaulle qui est notre richesse
grâce au nucléaire une énergie qui comme
vous le disiez émotionné nous permet de
donner mettre quasiment pas de co2 cette
énergie que vous qualifiez monsieur
professeur d'énergie verte oui mesdames
et messieurs bonjour merci pour un mode
pour l'invitation
je suis passionné de solaire aussi mais
effectivement je vais vous parler du
nucléaire
un certain nombre d'entre nous et
d'entre vous ont été surpris lors des
discussions de la cap 21 d'entendre
pratiquement systématiquement les termes
clean energy traduit par énergies
renouvelables et pour les anglo saxons
le nucléaire est vraiment une énergie
propre et et pas seulement et pas
seulement par rapport au problème du co2
les femmes et les hommes qui ont bâti ce
programme qui ont construit cette
magnifique outil industriel qu'est le
nôtre outils nucléaire qu'il exploite
aujourd'hui qui gère les déchets à notre
place d'ailleurs n'ont pas attendu le
co2 pour en faire vraiment un modèle
d'une vraie réussite humaine ça je peux
en témoigner parce que j'ai été aussi de
longues années dans cette industrie la
technique
une réussite aussi environnemental est
vraiment un modèle de réussite
environnementale voilà je tenais à leur
rendre hommage parce qu'en plus c'est
les gens qui que je considère moi
personnellement comme étant des vrais
écologistes des écologistes en action
c'est eux qui font les gestes faut pas
croire que c'est les autorités de sûreté
nucléaire qui ont créé la la sûreté
c'est bien les exploitants nucléaires
qui sont en train de faire ce travail
pour nous aujourd'hui qui le font
brillamment depuis 40 ans voilà quand je
tiens à leur rendre hommage parce qu'ils
se sentent souvent incompris critiqué
par les autres écologistes passeur en
action mais ce en paroles et en critique
qui pourtant consomment leur énergie
nucléaire qui représente que vous savez
75 % de ce qui passe dans nos
installations électriques
voila j'aimerais si je si je peux
rappeler quelques faits le nucléaire ça
représente aujourd'hui dans ce pays
49 % de la puissance électrique
installée et je dirais ça ne présente
que 49 % de la puissance installée alors
alors que le nucléaire produit comme on
vient de le dire en 2015 c'était 76 % de
notre électricité
à ça et c'est la seule énergie qui peut
se vanter de cette prouesse la de ce
ratio pour toutes les autres énergies
celle inverse à cause comme ça a été dit
par mes voisins de justement
l'intermittence notamment mais des
renouvelables
il ya quatre raisons à ça d'abord parce
que l'énergie nucléaire est encore la
moins chère alors je j'entends avec
vraiment boonen gilbert les prix qui ont
été annoncées sur le solaire mais
aujourd'hui le parc installé et tels que
l'énergie nucléaire la moins chère et si
vous voulez vous en convaincre je vous
invite à lire les les rapports 2012 et
2014 de la cour des comptes qui a
vraiment fait une analyse très fouillée
qui répond à toutes les critiques qui
ont pu être faites et qui aboutit donc à
des coûts entre 33 et 59 euros du
mégawattheures suivant la façon de
calculer mais sur coup sûr tous et les
coûts qui intègre bien la totalité des
coûts passés des coûts futurs
j'ai même été surpris de lire dans ce
rapport que tous les coûts de la
recherche et 55 milliards depuis 1957
sont bien intégrés et n'en déplaise à
certains antinucléaires tous les coûts
futurs
bien sûr il ya l'incertitude sur les
coûts futurs de démantèlement de gestion
des déchets les 88 milliards de
démantèlement qui sont déjà à moitié
provisionné c'est une des rares
industries où nous consommateurs avons
déjà payé à l'avancé dépenses qui vont
se faire sur les cent prochaines années
tous ces coups en font bien partie et ça
c'est la cour des comptes qu'il dit ça
c'est la cour des comptes qu'il dit
effectivement ce genre de messages sont
rarement clairement relayées dans la
presse mais c'est la réalité je vous
invite à lire c'est vrai que ces délits
en rapport
ils sont vraiment parfaitement documenté
donc première raison c'est l'énergie la
moins chère deuxième région deuxième
raison à ce succès du nucléaire c'est
que nos biens produits à la demande
c'est pas une énergie aléatoire et à la
différence donc comme ça vient d'être
dit de l'éolien ou du photovoltaïque qui
si on fait une une allusion aux marchés
automobiles qui étaient cités tout à
l'heure ce sont des énergies qui
j'aime bien c'est cette image qui oblige
acheter une deuxième voiture qui démarre
quand on en a besoin pour remplacer
celle très à la mode bien sûr le solaire
qui ne démarre que quand elle en a envie
et c'est un peu ça aujourd'hui le
problème du renouvelable
troisième raison ça a été dit à ce
succès nucléaire qui n'émet pas de co2
et quatrième raison très importante en a
pas encore beaucoup parler mais c'est
que plus on utilise cette énergie
nucléaire
plus on augmente notre indépendance
énergétique nationale et on améliore la
balance commerciale je pense que vous
connaissez les chiffres sur 250 millions
de tonnes d'équivalent pétrole de
consommation d'énergie primaire on en
produit aujourd'hui à peu près 140
millions de tonnes
le nucléaire donc ça fait si vous faites
le ratio ça fait 50 6% d'indépendance
énergétique
c'est exceptionnel pour un pays qui n'a
pas de pétrole c'est donc un autre signe
de cette réussite et j'allais justement
corriger une erreur qui a été fait tout
à l'heure sur ces 140 millions de tonnes
de production d'énergie primaire
le nucléaire représente 82% mais en
deuxième position c'est pas
l'hydraulique
c'est la biomasse qui représente 11% et
c'est un point qu'il était mal connu si
on regarde la répartition des
renouvelables dans ce pays en terme
d'énergie primaire
sur les 25 millions de tonnes
d'équivalent pétrole d'énergie
renouvelables la biomasse représente 65%
c'est à dire deux fois plus que
l'hydraulique dix fois plus que l'éolien
est 25 fois plus que le photovoltaïque
donc ça aussi c'est les chiffres qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est l'effet c'est
pas des croyances et donc voilà le
paysage aujourd'hui
on doit faire évoluer sur lesquels il
faut s'appuyer pour pour aller au delà
alors alors peut-être attend jean louis
tu nous as fait l'état des lieux c'est
vrai que ça nous a bien éclairé enfin
j'espère que ça vous a bien éclairé
c'est passionnant juste un point
invoquons pas sur la stratégie nationale
énergétique sur les questions purement
politique en matière fessenheim ou pas
il ya beaucoup de sujets encore qu'il
faut aborder la taxe carbone comment
financer ces des questions fondamentales
et puis je vois le solaire qui veut
qu'il veut intervenir juge jean-louis un
mot peut-être quand même sur sur les
solides déchets sur comment on va faire
évoluer ce nucléaire on n'est pas en
train de signer un chèque en blanc non
plus à au nucléaire il faut bien faire
évoluer aussi cette filière est ce qu'il
ya des possibilités de nouvelles
technologies qui qui seront peut-être
encore plus verte qui géreront mieux
leurs déchets qui auront un meilleur
rendement et dont la sécurité surtout
sera cru bon les déchets je vais venir
mais ce que je tiens à dire ici dans
cette salle c'est que pour moi le
l'énergie nucléaire c'est vraiment une
énergie verte a causé déchets à venir
mais on a toujours tendance
quand on veut citer des énergies vertes
et la plupart des écologistes pense
d'abord au solaire et à l'éolien parce
que ben le vent et le soleil sont
naturels alors bien sûr les les
éoliennes et les capteurs solaires sont
moins naturels sont pas plus naturel que
nos réacteurs nucléaires mais sur ce
point me ou premiers points déjà le
l'énergie nucléaire pour moi est une
énergie naturelle c'est probablement
l'énergie la plus répandue dans
l'univers la fusion fait briller le
soleil et les étoiles sur cette terre on
sait que la radioactivité omniprésente
on est tous autant que nous sommes dans
cette salle chargée de radioactivité
j'ai même été vraiment surpris
agréablement surpris dans les émissions
de ces derniers
jour sur les anniversaires de tchernobyl
de voir à quel point les gens de pripiat
ou de fukushima avait pu d'une part
vaincre leur peur dès qu'on leur a remis
entre les mains des moyens de mesure
parce qu'ils ont pu s'apercevoir que la
radioactivité comme l'a très bien dit un
japonais qui était un fantôme auparavant
il a pu s'apercevoir que ce fantôme
était dangereuse peut être à quelques
endroits mais qui avait pas de
radioactivité dans leur maison qu'à
certains autres endroits ils pouvaient
faire les cultures et j'ai été vraiment
agréablement surpris de voir que
puisqu'on parle de sécurité la sécurité
alimentaire en fait partie que on
commercialise en ukraine autour de
tchernobyl et autour de fukushima du
lait qui est en dessous de 100
becquerels par kilo ça vous parlera
peut-être pas mais c'est moins que la
radioactivité dont celle du césium 137
mais c'est moins que la radioactivité
que nous portons nous dans nos corps
humain qui représente à peu près 120
becquerels par kilo voilà donc la
radioactivité naturelle
le nucléaire est naturel il est naturel
aussi parce que ben il ya eu des
réacteurs nucléaires naturel à au clos
gabon il ya deux milliards d'années
on les a pas inventé donc tout un tas de
raisons pour dire que le nucléaire est
naturelle et qu' il a rien à envier sur
ce paramètre là avec les énergies
renouvelables mais c'est aussi une
énergie verte pour moi parce que c'est
une énergie compact qui prend beaucoup
moins de place
no 19 centrales direct des éoliennes et
des capteurs photovoltaïques occuperait
30 % ou 50 50 fois plus de place pendant
30 ou 50 fois plus de places
respectivement que que les réacteurs
nucléaires
alors pour parler du déchet pour parler
des déchets
moi je pense que les déchets aujourd'hui
on en parle beaucoup des déchets je sais
pas si beaucoup de ceux qui critiquent
le nucléaire en sortant toujours ce
critère des déchets auront déjà vu tout
le monde en parle peu en a eu la chance
d'en voir moi moi qui ai vu le necker de
l'intérieur je considère que les déchets
nucléaires aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un
défaut du nucléaire c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui une qualité c'est une des
activités qui est parfaitement maîtrisée
depuis plusieurs décennies
d'abord il faut savoir que 90 % des
déchets nucléaires ont des solutions qui
sont en oeuvre et qui sont parfaitement
éprouvés et hyper contrôlée
réglementairement et démocratiquement
on ne fait pas ce qu'on veut dans ce
domaine là donc les déchets aujourd'hui
représente là pour la plupart des
activités qui sont parfaitement
maîtrisés alors vous allez me dire oui
mais il ya 0 2 % des déchets les fameux
produits de fission qui sort des
réacteurs nucléaires qui contiennent 98%
de la radioactivité
oui certes mais on sait exactement ce
qu'il faut en faire aujourd'hui ils sont
vitrifiés en tout cas dans ce pays où on
a opté pour le recyclage ils sont
vitrifiés
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire les pouvoirs
publics ont une décision à prendre c'est
vrai pour autoriser ce magnifique projet
cigéo de stockage géologique profond
dans une couche d'argile à 500 mètres de
profondeur une couche qui est stable
depuis 160 millions d'années pour
stocker des déchets qui vont faire quoi
simplement décroître et qui au bout de
dix mille ans or on atteindra 10 un
niveau de radioactivité qui sera celui
de d'un simple minerai d'uranium naturel
donc la solution existe ce projet tout
le monde nous envie
donc les déchets aussi pour moi c'est
vraiment une activité verte du nucléaire
et à deux autres qui sont la durabilité
et la recyclabilité si je peux me
permettre durable l'objection est
souvent de dire l'uranium
on en a pas en france on importe
pourquoi on importe tout simplement
parce qu'aujourd'hui le marché de
l'uranium est parfaitement fluide
à la différence des hydrocarbures on en
trouve partout l'uranium
si on creuse dans le jardin de cette
maison on en trouvera on en achète au
niger au kazakhstan en australie au
canada parce que le marché est beaucoup
moins cher que l'uranium pour tous dans
notre pays mais il faut savoir que dans
ce petit pays qui est une confettis
la france on a exploité 170 mines
d'uranium on a extrait 70 mille tonnes
d'uranium
donc ce n'est pas un problème non plus
et puis je voudrais parler du
renouvelable
et puis je m'arrête là est ce que est ce
que le nucléaire et renouvelables il le
sera demain grâce comme vous l'avez dit
aux réacteurs de génération 4 qui
produiront autant de matière fissile
qu'ils n'en consomment
et si c'est pas ça la définition de
l'art nouvelles habilités c'est au moins
une durabilité pour des milliers
d'années
merci pour tout pour tous ces éléments
wii est sûre je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est vraiment passionnant et c'est
vraiment le genre du terrain qui nous
raconte
voilà ce qu'il en est on à t'écouter je
fais le parallèle avec marcel kunz qui
nous a parlé tout à l'heure chercheur au
cnrs et qui ne disaient qu'il fallait
analyser vraiment le bénéfice est liée
aux risques et c'est ce que tu sais ce
que tu fais je vais donner la parole à
dominique louis oz président-directeur
général d'assystem et c'est vrai que
toutes ces questions vous êtes un des
spécialistes aussi de ce secteur
nucléaire et par rapport
avantage ou redange et une choses
basiques
le grand avantage du nucléaire c'est
qu'une petite pastille de 7 g c'est
l'équivalent énergétique d'une tonne de
charbon dans un réacteur nucléaire
disons d'origine on met à peu près 11
millions de pastilles et donc dans ces
sept grammes il y en a que 10 % qui sont
effectivement du combustible fissile
et il y en a 90 % qui servent à rien et
quand on regarde le problème des déchets
donc si vous voulez ce 11 millions de
pastilles s'appelle 77 tonnes mais ça
occupe un tout petit volume compte tenu
de la densité qui avait à peu près de
l'ordre de 20 ça ferait c'était compact
et 4 mètres cubes et les déchets au bout
de cinq ans puisque une charge de ce
type là pourrait fonctionner cinq ans
donc c'est l'équivalent 10 millions de
tonnes de charbon 11 millions de tonnes
de charbon puisqu'une plastiscines
tonnes de charbon est la chimie pour les
nuls le co2 11 millions de tonnes de
charbon
ces 22 millions de tonnes de co2 en gros
c'est demain à deux donc l'intérêt
fondamental du nucléaire c'est
effectivement concentration d'énergie
alors après le sujet des déchets
effectivement dans les déchets dans les
10 % il ya la france a fait le choix du
recyclage c'est à dire de valoriser le
conduit
cible usées c'est un peu comme descendre
dans lesquels on va extraire du
plutonium qui nous a servi pour
effectivement faire nos armes nucléaires
mais ensuite le plutonium via une usine
qui s'appelle melox on leur dit lui pour
en faire du combustible et donc il reste
vraiment 5 % de déchets ultimes
mais 6 5% déchets ultimes pour un
réacteur sur cinq ans ça tient dans le
coffre d'une clio dire quand on parle
des déchets des volumes faut voir de
quoi on parle et le projet cigéo
effectivement d'enfouissement savez pour
tout le programme français pour les 58
réacteurs pendant 40 ans et y aura
encore de la place donc c'est vrai que
c'est un vrai sujet c'est à dire que ces
déchets ils vont il faut les il faut les
isolés on les dit trifi on sait pas
exactement si un jour on pourra les
reprendre mais c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement compact j'allais dire
aujourd'hui effectivement l'industrie
nucléaire dès le début est parti sur une
vision de confinement de son cycle c'est
à dire qu on enrichit l'uranium
on le brûle et l'ailé les déchets sont
les retraites et tout ça est confiné
c'est l'anti risque systémique
le nucléaire c'est l'anti risque
systémique est une technologie qui est
mature alors j'allais dire quand
j'entendais je pense que la vraie
solution c'est effectivement la
compatibilité entre nucléaire est et le
renouvelable suis pas spécialisé
renouvelables mais quand j'entends le
100% renouvelable
aujourd'hui avec les technologies
connues moi je suis un peu inquiet parce
que aujourd'hui tout ce qui est ce mardi
si vous voulez quand vous avez d'un côté
préfère tout ce que vous voulez
aujourd'hui pas de capacité de stockage
donc malgré tout pouvait avoir des les
mathématiciens bullies on peut prédire
le climat on peut et sait vous trouver
leur une solution 100% renouvelable et
en face une consommation c'est quand
même être un peu apprentis sorciers la
preuve est que contrairement à ce que
disent certains écologistes entendu que
finalement le nucléaire c'est l énergie
les dictatures et que finalement les
vraies démocraties n'est pas nucléaire
quels sont les grands pays du nucléaire
dans le monde
vous avez les états unis qui a 100
réacteurs qui est ce qui a le plus de
projets nucléaires aujourd'hui dans le
monde c'est la chine sert que la chine
elle joue les deux cartes
j'ai entendu effectivement les projets
renouvelables de lâcher sans réacteur
prévu en chine
elle y chinois veulent être en plus un
acteur du marché nucléaire dans le monde
puisqu'il développe leur propre
technologie
les alliances que les chinois sont en
train de faire aujourd'hui on pourrait
peut être en parler autour d'areva
c'est cette vision là alors on peut dire
même les américains c'est le passé ils
ont 100 réacteurs non les américains
aujourd'hui son parti dans un programme
donc il faut savoir qu'une centrale
nucléaire
la durée de vie initiale prévue ses 40
ans à la fois pour des raisons
technologiques et puis les autorisations
juridiques loitation les américains les
premiers ont décidé de prolonger la vie
à 60 ans pourquoi parce que nos
centrales nucléaires
vous pouvez tout changé sauf de choses
c'est génie civil du coeur ça c'est et
puis c'est le sait la chaudière elle
même c'est bon mais tout le reste ça se
change
et d'ailleurs ça se change donc une
autre idée une autre fausse idée c'est
l'idée que le parc vieillit et qu'on
arriverait une situation critique ou les
centrales deviennent très dangereuse
c'est pas vrai le nucléaire c'est comme
les outils tout ce qui se changer et
échanger d'ailleurs idf des programmes
nous sommes de nos principales activités
depuis vingt ans des programmes de ce
qu'on appelle de d'entretien de carénage
où certains composants importants alors
peu importe des générateurs de vapeur
sont changés tous les dix ans et c'est
ce qui fait que tant que le coeur la
chaudière est intègre
le béton est intègre autres centrales
jouent alors si je suis pro 14 chez les
quasiment neuf qui est par exemple la
situation de fessenheim
l'asn a dit stephen hayes n'y avait
aucune raison technique pour arrêter
fessenheim alors professionnels
justement j'allais donner la parole à
hervé mariton mais merci pour ces
explications parce qu'on a bien bien
compris quand même l'ensemble on est
quand même dans une idéologie
on va essayer de revenir ici aux
républicains par un pragmatisme on va
tout à l'heure et évoquer avec jean
claude lenoir la stratégie nationale de
la france est totalement le fait que
nous allons revenir sur cette loi sur la
transition énergétique et sur cette
diminution de la part du nucléaire qui
n'est pas aujourd'hui plausible
d'arrêter une vingtaine de réacteurs
d'ici une dizaine d'années mais alors
pour le cas spécifique de fessenheim est
vrai que partout on en a entendu parler
on s'est amusé à se faire peur ou
certains se sont amusés à faire peur aux
français alors que l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire indiqué qu'il n'avait aucune
difficulté voire pire et vers méritons
vous allez nous le rappeler avait imposé
travaux que le gouvernement a lui-même
réalisé pour ensuite après revenir en
dix ans on a fait les travaux
maintenance est assurée mais on
la firme est quand même donc un peu une
incohérence on joue un double langage
est ce que c'est pour des techniques
purement électoralistes je crois qu'on
peut le dire comme cela alors sur
fessenheim et pour poursuivre le propos
de dominique louis il n'y a aucun
argument de sûreté nucléaire qui peut
justifier de fermer la centrale avec
ensuite une espèce de paradoxes qui suit
de la politique de sûreté nucléaire en
france qui est que dans la ligne de ce
que demande l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire depuis longtemps les centrales
au moment de leur renouvellement
je t'en prie les centrales au moment de
leur renouvellement doivent être au
maximum de sûreté exiger des nouvelles
installations
et donc si on suit ce raisonnement on a
des centrales qui au fond peuvent durer
une éternité
on se rend compte que ça ça n'est pas
possible donc à un moment il faut tout
de même avoir l'idée qu'une génération
puisse succéder à une autre simplement
comme l'a dit dominique louis au delà
des 40 ans connue en france aujourd'hui
ça peut être 50 ça peut être 60 sont les
perspectives américaines des 80 et qui
ne pose pas de difficulté en tant que
tel
ensuite quel est le coût en face nicolas
a rappelé dans son entretien samedi
qu'on l'avait évalué ce coût à quelque
chose de l'ordre de 300 millions d'euros
le bénéfice annuel
le bénéfice annuel de fessenheim étaient
300 millions d'euros ce qui nous avait
amené avec marc goua dans un rapport à
considérer que le coût médian
d'indemnisation de fermeture de
fessenheim serait autour de 4 milliard
d'euros alors fait modeste par rapport à
ce chiffre
parce que l'évolution du prix de
l'électricité aujourd'hui fait que ce
chiffrage et est devenu un peu fragile
mais en même temps le prix de
l'électricité dans les années qui
viennent
ne restera probablement par au bas
niveau qui est aujourd'hui dans tous les
cas c'est une perte de résultats
économiques et c'est potentiellement sur
fessenheim ou sur les autres réacteurs a
fermé la vingtaine de réacteurs qui a
été citée par la cour des comptes le
rapport a été rappelé leur un coup
absolument extravagants pour le
contribuable et ça c'est un point
extrêmement faible dans la loi de
transition énergétique
c'est le changement du mix français un
rythme fort c'est l'idée qu'on n'est pas
éternellement 75 % d'électricité
produite avec du nucléaire
est une idée qui en termes de bon sens
de base ne pas mettre tous ses oeufs
dans le même panier est une idée
recevable ce qui est absolument stupide
ruineux et totalement idéologique dans
la loi de transition énergétique
c'est de dire pas plus de 50%
d'électricité nucléaire en 2025
c'est impossible c'est ruineux c'est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui tels que ça a été
voté même très grave sur le plan
politique et démocratique parce qu'au
fond le texte a été voté que dans l'idée
qu'ils seraient jamais mis en oeuvre
vous aurez beaucoup de mal à trouver des
gens raisonnables en france qui se
disent que la loi votée par le parlement
sera mise en oeuvre
même problème d'ailleurs s'agissant d'un
son d'énergies renouvelables et moi j'ai
beaucoup apprécié le propos de fabien
choné parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez un
sombre de programmes sur le renouvelable
électrique
je pense en particulier un son de
projets d'éolien en mer ou les porteurs
de projets eux-mêmes pris le ciel que ce
ne soit jamais réalisés tant l'enjeu est
en réalité insurmontable économiquement
et là dessus je crois qu'on a besoin et
je trouve que le document qui nous a été
présenté est très clair et très cohérent
on a besoin d'une vision stratégique
forte faire du renouvelable de
substitution aux hydrocarbures
ça a beaucoup de sens pour des raisons
économiques pour des raisons de
souveraineté pour des raisons
d'indépendance énergétique le
renouvelables électriques à marche
forcée telle qu'elle a été engagée n'a
strictement aucun sens il est inapte à
deux sens au plan industriel parce que
nous n'avons pas de filière industrielle
en france il n'a pas beaucoup de sens
sur le plan environnemental
quand ça amène à bousiller des paysages
avec l'éolien en crète
mais quand ça amène aussi quand ça amène
aussi des empreintes carbone très
significatives au moment de l'addition
de ces équipements
ces ruines pour le contribuable vous
êtes passé mode rapidement mais c'est
extrêmement important sur la taxe
carbone elle est traduite aujourd'hui et
la contribution climat énergie
il faut que nos concitoyens est une idée
d ordre de grandeur la contribution
climat énergie c'est un impôt socialiste
extrêmement commode parce que même les
plus éclairés dans la salle ne savent
pas combien ils payent par an de
contribution climat énergie la réalité
n'en est pas moins que dans la
trajectoire voulue par le gouvernement
socialiste
c'est une augmentation programmée de 20
centimes d'euro de la fiscalité du
gazole d'ici 2020
et 30 centimes d'euros d'ici 2030 on est
sur des enjeux absolument considérable
pour financer une transition énergétique
à marche forcée qu'il y ait dans le
temps une évolution ça se conçoit
mais cette transition telle qu'elle est
programmée n'a aucun sens et avec des
scénarios de croissance verte qui sont
irréalisables intenable et vous avez eu
raison de le souligner les emplois à la
clé ne sont pas véritablement présent
donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on comprenne
bien un mode ce qu'est la menace
immédiate et je crois qu'il faut qu'on
soit clair j'ai entendu le président des
républicains s'exprimer mais je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord sur le fait que
la fermeture de fessenheim
c'est une faute il est à craindre que le
gouvernement engage un son de mesures
réglementaires pour des raisons
idéologiques avant la fin d'année
il faudra qu'on ait la capacité de
revenir dessus eco reste c'est tout ce
pan de la loi de transition énergétique
qui devraient être modifiés sauf à
ruiner les français et a ruiné non
seulement une filière industrielle mais
un véritable enjeu pour l'environnement
mais merci à hervé mariton je crois
qu'on est on est tous d'accord sur la
semaine et phase de cette idéologie et
qui a été porté par la gauche ces
derniers mois je voulais entendre
dernièrement avant de passer la parole à
notre président jean claude lenoir qui
est sénateur de l'or mais qui est
président de la commission des affaires
économiques et qui à cette vision pour
cette stratégie énergétique française
qui doit être aussi une stratégie
énergétique européenne et c'est pour ça
que je voulais après qu'ont conclu avec
le professeur salanave sur la fameuse
taxe carbone parce que il est inutile à
la fois demandé de fermer fessenheim et
en allemagne juste à nos frontières de
polluer cette fois plus que nous et de
nous polluer avec ses émissions de co2
donc cette stratégie elle est
fondamentale d'abord une petite remarque
cette cession est consacré d'énergie on
ne parle que de l'électricité
l'électricité représente 23% de
l'énergie en france le reste basse et ce
qui est nécessaire pour les véhicules
les usines le à l'entendre parler avant
de rappeler je veux quand même le
rappeler est à l'intérieur de 23%
nucléaire c'est 18% soit 18% du tout
alors parlons parlons d'une vision à
long terme pour ce qui concerne
l'énergie d'abord contrairement à ce qui
a pu être dit il n'y a pas d'énergie
gratuite
je vais vous donner quelques chiffres le
parc nucléaire français compte 58
réacteurs
ils ont coûté en euros actualisé 98,8
milliards d'euros l'allemagne dans le
même temps les produits 75% et visiter
l'allemagne dans le pas dans le même
temps parce que le programme est plus
récent investi dans l'éolien et dans le
photovoltaïque 115 milliards d'euros
pour produire 20 % de l'électricité
consommée en allemagne
je voulais quand même le rappeler ça
veut dire que l'énergie n'est jamais
gratuite
le problème aujourd'hui sur le marché de
l'électricité
c'est que vous avez un certain nombre de
pays qui nous touchent de près je ne
veux pas citer en particulier mais il y
en a un très gros à l'est de la france
qui est très subventionné tellement
subventionnée que d'ailleurs les
consommateurs et les contribuables
aujourd'hui n'en peuvent plus ils
réclament une révision de la politique
faut quand même le rappeler
pour autant ça vient perturber notre
marché moi j'ai sous les yeux un tableau
de bord qui me permet de connaître
heure par heure la situation de
l'énergie en france
crt e réseau transport de l'énergie qui
nous le dit alors je vais vous dire
actuellement on relève arrive hein voilà
on exporte en export de l'électricité
dans tous les pays sauf dans un un qui
nous vend de l'électricité c'est
allemagne l'allemagne parce que
l'électricité coûte beaucoup moins cher
à certains moments mais c'est pas
seulement de l'énergie qui les
oliveraies du photovoltaïque
ça vient du charbon l'allemagne fait le
choix qu'on nous avons conformément aux
choix qui ont été faits avec la loi
transition énergétique choisi le
décarbonés l'allemagne dire mais on fait
du décarbonée
je veux bien enfin le taux de pollution
par tête d'habitant en allemagne et de
beaucoup plus élevé que notre devoir
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'ils aient un
quiz et j'étais il ya quelques quelques
jours un déjeuner débat autour de
l'ambassade du duo à l'ambassadeur
d'allemagne en france et nous invitait à
comprendre que en allemagne notamment
dans la région frontalière de la france
les automobilistes puissent avoir des
sticks sur leur pare-brise dit disant
non au nucléaire
je lui ai dit monsieur l'ambassadeur je
me permets avec beaucoup de respect de
vous dire que nous allons inciter nos
automobilistes en alsace à m non aux ses
hôtes eux parce que il faut quand même
il faut quand même faut quand même
rétablir rétablir les alors le choix du
nucléaire ne doit pas être remis en
cause revient pas sur fessenheim fait
saddam est quand même une centrale
nucléaire
l agence sûreté nucléaire a donné dix
ans de plus au 30 ans pendant lesquels
elle a fonctionné
donc si au moins il ya une centrale
nucléaire pour laquelle il eut un visa
de l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
c'est bien fessenheim la loi transition
énergétique
rassurez vous elle ne sera jamais
appliquée pour ce qui concerne la
réduction de la part du nucléaire à 50%
d'ici à 2025
ce n'est pas possible déjà pour
fessenheim
il y avait un ministre de l'énergie
parmi d'ailleurs tous les milices de
l'énergie de ce quinquennat il ya une
fonction ministérielle qui est vraiment
très renouvelables et la fonction de
ministre en charge de l'énergie du
développement durable
alors là vraiment
4-4 ministrable il ya un ministre qui
s'appelait philippe martin qui avait dit
il ya deux ans je fermerai fessenheim en
attendez on ferme pas une centrale comme
ça il ya des procédures
elles sont administratives elles sont
techniques elles sont financières le
coup on le connaît il faudrait payer 4
milliards d'euros pour la simple
fermeture de fessenheim qui n'appartient
pas qu'à edf
il ya des capitaux suisses et allemands
alors il faut quand même le le rappeler
fessenheim va peut-être arrêter de
produire au bois de mai de l'année
prochaine
c'est pas pour autant que fait madame
sera fermée c'est là la subtilité
voiture arrêtée une centrale d'ailleurs
vous ont fait régulièrement pour
recharger en combustible
maintenant pour ce qui concerne les
autres réacteurs c'est vrai que le
calcul qui est fait d'ici à 2025 ça fait
vingt-quatre centrale réacteurs
nucléaires c'est strictement c'est
strictement impossible mais ce qu'il ne
produirait pas un coût qui est quand
même aujourd'hui beaucoup moins élevé
pour les centrales les plus anciennes
il est moins élevé tout simplement parce
que ce sont des installations qui sont
très largement amortis ne cédez jamais à
la tentation de suivre le propos qui
souvent circulent notamment dans les
médias on parle de vieilles centrales il
n'y a pas de vieille centrale nucléaire
elles sont toutes ajusté pour être au
top
or c'est justement ce que ce que nous
disait le professeur salanave peut-être
si vous permettez pas parce qu'on a un
petit peu de temps je voulais vraiment
qu'on arrive à conclure alors que le
vision avec la vision et la taxe carbone
parce que c'est quand même une ambition
européenne d'envergure il faut aller
vers une énergie décarbonée deux axes
deux axes importants
je vais revenir tout de suite face à
carbonne 1 c'est évidemment le nucléaire
on est à la troisième génération avec le
p r il y à un certain nombre de
difficultés que l'on connaît en finlande
en france
pas tellement chine d'ailleurs où
finalement ces deux réacteurs ont été
démarré plus tard que les autres ils
vont sans doute fonctionner avant avant
les autres ça pose un tas de questions
auxquelles je ne réponds pas aujourd'hui
mais la troisième génération et la
génération dont va s'emparer des chinois
c'est sûr aujourd'hui la part du
nucléaire va augmenter mais il faut
préparer la quatrième génération c'est
notre devoir c'est à nous de le faire
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un quatrième
génération ce sont des réacteurs qui
utiliseront pour fonctionner leurs
propres déchets c'est surgénérateur on a
on a connu une expérience avec
superphénix malheureusement compromise
par par le gouvernement jospin
la france a une capacité d'innovation
dans le domaine du nucléaire
extraordinaire nous sommes la meilleure
école pour ces concernent des
technologies du nucléaire
aujourd'hui ce serait gâcher si
évidemment le gouvernement en place et
est appelée à a duré mais voyons bien
que nous sommes
les porteurs des meilleures technologies
maintenant c'est pour s'habiller rien
sur un principe de responsabilité plutôt
qu'un principe de précaution tout à fait
avec une mise en avant de la recherche
est maintenant progrès j'en termine sur
la question fiscale carbone pourquoi
pourquoi certaines énergies polluantes
notamment venant qui viennent d'autres
ramés d'autres pays sont compétitives
parce que il n'y a pas de taxe carbone
la taxe carbone s'impose
je dois dire d'ailleurs le les pouvoirs
publics en france ont annoncé une taxe à
30,40 euros la tonne c'est c'est je
crois il faut le dire un minimum pas
pour nous nous nous produisons j'ai
encore un autre graphique permet de dire
que nous aujourd'hui au moment où je
parle
nous produisons électricité en utilisant
des hydrocarbures donc avec co2 gaz à
effet de serre à hauteur de 6% et donc
les 94% qui reste c'est du renouvelable
donc c'est n'est d'accord il c'est pour
ça que j'attends c'est la lisent les
indiscrétions c'est une orientation il
faut absolument imposer une taxe carbone
qui ne pénalisera pas tellement la
france mes affaires sombres pays et
enfin j'en termine
oui arrêtons arrêtons de courber l
échine je crois que nous sommes les bons
élèves en europe
il ya qu un pays qui est devant nous
poursuit concerne sa part sa
contribution co2
la suède nous sommes les seconds les
dossiers deuxième tous les autres sont
derrière et certains pays parmi les plus
gros sont très très très loin derrière
soyons fiers de ce que nous avons fait
voilà et tâchant prendre les bonnes
décisions pour le reste et on va écouter
notre président vous l'avez vu depuis ce
matin l'écologie l'environnement c'est
pas l'apanage de la gauche
on a beaucoup travaillé ici au parti
pour vous proposer des solutions qui
soient concrètes et qui serait surtout
applicables
je salue la présence de christian
estrosi avec lequel on travaille
ardemment je l'en remercie d'être là
ardemment la région paca et qui le dit
mieux que moi que l'écologie doit rimer
avec l'économie je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est l'avenir on veut mettre en place
également les assises de l'environnement
en paca et on veut mettre en application
ce qu'on vous dit
aujourd'hui ça sera un projet
d'alternance en 2017 mais nous on va
l'appliquer d'ici les prochains mois
merci à tous
monsieur le président